joe rogan who was a bernie bro right
he's not exactly a rock-ribbed
conservative
but he's seeing what we're all seeing
he's seeing
that in the world of critical race
theory and intersectionality and
woke politics and a racial caste system
being voiced by the left
we are increasingly living in a world in
which
straight white dudes are not allowed
to talk joe i think you made the point
beautifully
you can never be woke enough that's the
problem it keeps going it keeps going
further and further and further down the
line and if you get to the point where
you capitulate where you agree to all
these demands
it will eventually get to straight white
men are not allowed to talk
right because it's your privilege to
express yourself when other people of
color have been silenced throughout
history
it will be you're not allowed to go
outside
because so many people were imprisoned
for so many years i mean i'm not joking
no i know i know
it really will get there it's that crazy
you know we just got to be nice to each
other man
and there's a lot of people that are
taking advantage
of this weirdness in our culture and
then that becomes
their thing their thing is calling
people out for their privilege
calling people out for their position
he's obviously right i mean we're
already told this
we we are already told that certain
people are not allowed that uh
it's not just certain people straight
white men are not allowed to voice their
opinion
on certain issues and it goes back
further even than the woke blm craziness
goes back on the issue of abortion we're
told men are not allowed to have an
opinion on abortion
i'm pretty sure they are first of all
very often it's men who
state that opinion and they say a lot
you know i'm a liberal man and i think
that men
should just be quiet about abortion like
okay buddy take your own advice and shut
up then
because i do have here's my here's my
crazy outrageous
patriarchal opinion uh
killing babies is bad it's bad it's
always bad and you shouldn't do it ever
even if it's like a crying baby even
even if that baby you know is kind of
sometimes you know it's four in the
morning you hear that baby crying well
even then that's my opinion i am
a human being i have faculties of reason
i am a citizen of this country i
participate in the body politic
and so yeah i'm allowed to have that
opinion i'm allowed to voice it
and frankly that opinion should carry
the day and everybody else should listen
to that opinion and recognize that that
is the correct opinion
okay but we're told no you're not
allowed to have that opinion we're
increasingly told
that a white people specifically white
men are not allowed
to voice an opinion on blm or police
brutality or whatever because we have
not had the lived experience
of whatever you know people who who have
experienced the cops pulling them over
by the way i've been pulled over by cops
plenty of times because i have a little
bit of a lead foot
but no it doesn't matter well my skin is
kind of swarthy doesn't matter not
swirly enough
you don't have the lived experience and
of course at the heart of this is a
radical subjectivism
which says you don't have faculties of
reason actually critical race theory
says this
you don't have faculties of reason you
can't rely on them you can't know
anything about the objective world
all you can know is the reality of your
own subjective
suffering and by the way you white guys
have never suffered
well how do you know about the reality
of my subjective suffering if you're
you're telling me you can't okay you can
know but i can't know okay
understood we are already being told
this sort of thing
and there's another irony here we're
told that white supremacy pervades the
whole
country and the words based on white
supremacy pew research did a survey
a couple years back of racial
consciousness
asked people how how important is your
race to your identity
for every racial group other than white
people
most respondents said that race is
either very or extremely important to
their sense of identity
for white people the number was 15
percent
so you've got you've got at least some
somewhat important you know you've got
some level of importance
50 of every other racial group except
for white white people have the lowest
racial identity by far of anybody
in the country which is why we're so
shocked and that's why we get offended
when they call us racist
but it's as joe rogan is saying here
it's just an exploitation it's an
emotional sort of exploitation
we're talking a lot about immunity and
inoculations and things these days
i am pleased to report that i am
completely immune to white guilt i just
don't feel it it's not i'm immune to
male
guilt i'm pretty soon we're gonna have
straight guilt i'm immune to that too
i just don't feel it if you do feel that
in
any way it is because you are buying
into the leftist
vision of the world which is perverse
and anti-historical
and wicked and wrong and you just got to
get shut of it lose
it throw it out the window and things
will make a bit more sense
if you don't ring that bell right now
you are a racist you are a sexist
and you are endangering hundreds of
millions of americans am i doing that
right i'm trying to be as persuasive as
the mainstream media are
well that's it you gotta subscribe you
gotta like that's how you'll get
notifications otherwise you're
you'll be the worst person in the world
and listen to me and listen to me
all right enough of my don lemon
subscribe we'll see you next time